the story is set in the not so distant
future in Miami Florida where the
catastrophic effects of climate change
have caused widespread flooding and
scorching temperatures the city has
become a shadow of its former self with
many of its residents forced to conduct
their businesses and other activities at
night due to the unbearable heat poverty
is rampant and some of the inhabitants
are forced to live and makeshift slums
or even boats in this Bleak and
depressing environment people are
desperately holding on to memories of
happier times Nick and Emily both
ex-soldiers have set up a unique
business called reminiscence tank this
service allows people to relive their
Fondest Memories using a combination of
sedatives and cutting-edge Technology
Nick can even visualize and share their
memories in a holographic form making
the experience more surreal Avatar 3
here we come the scene then shifts to
Nick's acquaintance from the Army Hank
who is using the reminiscent service
Nick takes him back to his sunny day 13
years ago when he was playing with his
beloved pet dog as Hank reliefs this
cherished memory Nick describes the
sensation of reminiscence as a powerful
drug that allows people to reconnect
with their loved ones and relive the
most significant moments of their lives
however Nick also warns that excessive
Indulgence in these memories can lead to
a dangerous addiction trapping people in
their past and robbing them of the
present but the present is [__] who
cares finally Nick reveals that every
memory experienced by the clients
through the reminiscence tank are stored
on small flash drives further
highlighting the potential risks
associated with this service later at
night as Nick and Emily are about to
close their business for the day a
walk-in customer named May asks for help
in finding her missing Keys as soon as
Nick sees me he is immediately attracted
to her and despite Emily mentioning that
it's too late he decides to help wasting
no time he equips her with the machine
and immerses her in a memory of her
morning routine while May is processing
her memory Nick observes it and sees
detailed things in her room Emily tells
him that may put the keys in her bag and
dropped them in the dressing room
despite this Nick continues with the
memory and learns that may is a
nightclub singer after the session is
over May leaves but inadvertently leaves
her earrings behind time for Nick to be
a Good Samaritan with a boner the next
night Nick visits the same nightclub
from maze memory with the sole purpose
of returning her earrings after May ends
her performance he approaches her and
the two have a small chat when he
returns your earrings out of nowhere May
requests him to escort her to her
apartment Nick who at this point has
become flabbergasted by her beauty
agrees without thinking twice and as
soon as the two reach home they make
passionate love after their intimate
encounter neck and may have a
heart-to-heart conversation on the
rooftop May any questions why Nick
doesn't use the memory tank more often
to which the latter explains that
memories are better in small doses
suddenly it is revealed that Nick has
been in the reminiscence tank this whole
time thinking about May everything was
only in his imagination Emily tries to
get him out of the tank but Nick simply
can't stop thinking about his dream girl
it turns out May mysteriously
disappeared a few months ago and now
Nick is trying to figure out her
whereabouts by using the reminiscence
tank again and again he frequently
visits the club where she used to work
and asks a friend for Clues but to no
avail when nothing works Nick takes a
sedative and goes back to his memories
of May one time he wakes up to a loud
banging on his front door frustrated and
half asleep Nick angrily yells at the
person on the other side before storming
out to confront them but when he opens
the door he finds no one there only a
pair of earrings lying on the ground
Nick realizes that the earrings belong
to his ex-girlfriend May and tells Emily
about this however she dismisses it
saying that the earrings could have been
there for a while later the two visit
the police station to extract memories
from a dying criminal named Miles Nick
struggles to get any useful information
until he changes his approach and
discovers a conversation between miles's
boss Saint Joe and a corrupt cop named
Cyrus booth there at a nightclub and
surprisingly May is also there singing
she appears to be high on something as
the memory progresses Nick gets to know
that may stole a bag of Narcotics from
Saint Joe and ran away the following day
Nick travels to New Orleans and gains
entry to St Joe's Club using a fake name
unfortunately Josie's through his lies
and orders his men to beat him up when
Nick finally confesses that he's here to
find may Joe reveals that he hasn't seen
her since she stole from him he then
orders his henchmen to drown Nick things
look very Bleak for our protagonist but
right then Emily arrives out of nowhere
and starts fighting the guys despite
being outnumbered she executes every
single one of them with her accurate
shots and saves the day after they reach
Miami Nick says that he finds the whole
situation weird he believes may was
simply toying with him and that she must
have stolen something from them Emily
thinks he's being paranoid but Nick
reminds her of the last time she met may
he then asks her to get into the
reminiscence tank to investigate the
matter further in the memory we are
shown that before May vanished she came
to visit Emily holding a bottle of wine
the two talk about a lot of things
including their relationships and
families may also confesses that she is
a hardcore narcotic addict later when
Emily goes to the washroom Mae covertly
enters the memory Vault and steals a
memory chip in the present as soon as
Emily exits the tank she tries to defend
herself for hiding mei's drug addiction
however Nick does not give much weight
to it and rushes to the memory Vault
after searching for a while he learns
that the memory chip of a young woman
Elsa Karine is missing it turns out Elsa
was a regular client who also went
missing some weeks back the next day
Nick goes to a floating Market searching
for Elsa but learns that she is dead
furthermore her child Freddy was
kidnapped by a red-headed Woman matching
May's appearance the Revelation shocks
Nick and he begins to wonder if May was
a criminal despite this he continues
searching for her until a guy Corners
him inside an abandoned house and beats
his ass he threatens to kill Nick the
next time if he doesn't forget about May
after the attack Nick returns to his
office and immediately re-watches his
memory to search for Clues on closer
inspection he discovers that the
attacker is the same corrupt cop Cyrus
who worked for Saint Joe to find out
more about him Nick and Emily rushed to
the police station but they are stopped
by a huge crowd gathered outside it
turns out the wealthiest businessman in
town Sylvan has recently died currently
his widowed wife Tamara and their son
Sebastian are being escorted out as soon
as Nick sees Tamara he recognizes her as
a former client of the reminiscence tank
so he rushes to his office and begins
playing her memory where she is seen
dancing with her husband Sylvan
following this he also plays the memory
of Elsa who is enjoying her time with
her rich boyfriend when Nick compares
the two clips he finds similarities in
the man's voice which confirms that Elsa
was having an affair with none other
than Sylvan furthermore Freddy was born
because of their illicit relationship
after putting two and two together Nick
deduces the sylvan's other son Sebastian
hired Cyrus to kill Elsa and her son the
main motive is that he wants to be the
sole heir of his father's Fortune after
learning all of this Nick decides to get
to the bottom of everything so he leaves
his office carrying a gun in the
following scene an angry Nick arrives at
Tamara's residence she lives in the
richest part of Miami where lavishness
is still existent surprisingly Nick is
mistaken for a dancer who was called to
put on a show shake those titties wolvie
he doesn't resist though as it could be
his best chance to find answers soon
enough he meets Tamara and anger really
asks her about May and Elsa Tamara who
has lost a lot of her memory due to
depression reveals that Mae and Cyrus
were working together on something she
also seems to be aware that her husband
was having an affair with Elsa sadly
before Tamera can provide more
information Sebastian arrives and calls
for security thinking that Nick is
troubling his mother the guards
eventually throw him out but they also
assist him by revealing Cyrus's location
it turns out that even they are fed up
with the corrupt cop and they want him
dead afterward net goes to the subtle
location and notices a woman similar to
may he excitedly follows her but ends up
finding Cyrus waiting for him he is
humming a song which reminds Nick of his
first meeting with May Cyrus then
reveals that next meeting and
interaction with May were all planned
her only task was to manipulate Nick use
the reminiscence tank and steal Alice's
chip which contained memories of her
doing it with Sylvan Sylvan didn't want
anyone to know that he has a small
peepee saying this Cyrus flees from a
nearby window and Nick follows him there
the two get into a tussle which goes
back and forth for a while they fight in
the scorching sun and also underwater in
the end it is our brave protagonist who
emerges Victorious he then knocks Cyrus
out takes him to his office and puts him
in the reminiscence tank the corrupt
cop's memories reveal that May's
relationship with Nick was built on a
lie she actually worked for Cyrus and
pretended to be interested in Nick to
carry out a plan she even met many of
his friends to learn more about him and
gain his trust the Revelation stuns Nick
as all these months he had believed her
to be his soul mate however in another
memory it is shown that Cyrus was the
one who killed Elsa May witnessed all of
this so she immediately fled to an
unknown location with Freddy when Nick
inquires about his last meeting with May
Cyrus recollects his memory and shows
that he met her outside Nick's office
when she was knocking on the door he
dragged her away from there and this is
when Mae dropped one of her earrings
Nick angrily asks what he did to her and
Cyrus remembers assaulting her he also
forced her to reveal Freddie's location
by overloading her with narcotics
surprisingly May shows up on the
Hologram and speaks to Nick through
Cyrus's memories she expresses her love
for him while also hinting at where
Freddy is hiding she always knew that
Nick would capture Cyrus so that's why
she had left a secret message for him
unfortunately in the last memory Nick
gets to know that may committed the
unthinkable when the pressure became too
much for her devastated by her death
Nick decides to take revenge he ordered
Cyrus to remember his worst moment and
forces him to relive it again and again
the memory shows Cyrus's face being
burnt by Saint Joe's men as punishment
for stealing prophets however even this
is not enough for Nick so he increases
the voltage of Cyrus's Dreadful memory
and lets him die in the water tank hasta
la vista bub following this Nick goes
straight to sylvan's Residence and
confronts Sebastian for killing Elsa for
the sake of his father's wealth he also
reveals that he knows about his father's
affair with Elsa enraged and shocked
Sebastian tries to shoot Nick but
despite his best efforts he can't bring
himself to do it in the end he turns the
gun on himself and prepares to commit
the unthinkable however before things
can get bloody his mother arrives in the
neck of time and calms him down with the
situation resolved Nick goes to see
Emily and confesses to his crimes
recounting the entire story of May Cyrus
and their tangled web of Deceit he says
life is short so that's why Emily should
go back to her family and live with them
in his final moments Nick goes into the
reminiscence tank connects himself to
the wires and gets ready to start the
reminiscence process on himself soon we
see him reliving his memories with May
where the two confess their love for
each other before passing away
peacefully years later Emily visits Nick
at the reminiscence tank with her
daughter and leaves flowers for him the
movie ends with the message that while
living in the past can be dangerous
reliving memories of the best times can
be a way to find peace in the present
even if you become addicted to it and
you die
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching